i'm a pretty big uh star wars fan big  pretty big fan of star wars all right is  anybody else a big fan of star wars i  love star trek  they don't you don't even know what star  trek is yeah name it  captain bro captain  uh pointy ears kirk jesus what's the  name of russia that's what's the name of  the ship the starship trooper  [Laughter]  galactica or spock is what you're  thinking about or or pran solo number  one most famous quote from star trek  that everyone says number one quote from  how did he do it how did he do it he's  never seen one episode what's the track  then if all he says is that he's right  when he gets there when he gets there he  goes  right  end of season one  it's always a new trick